Hi, my name is Tamara Hus and I'm a patient of Dr. Connors and I was diagnosed with breast cancer
in July of 2016 and I saw several traditional oncologists and they all were telling me
different treatment options. One was saying strong chemo, one was saying mild chemo and one one actually
don't do the chemo at all if I didn't feel comfortable with it. So I was very, very torn and
I just felt like I needed some more answers and I felt like I was
you know unclear as to why this even happened to me. You know, I was young, healthy,
you know, it was very, very shocking to me to hear that news that I had cancer. So I just prayed
and prayed and prayed about it and I reached out to one of my very good childhood friends who
her mother had passed away from breast cancer and she said her mom had done chemo. She had
a recurrence and actually that was what she had passed away from. So I kind of questioned then
does chemo really even work or do anything? So she told me however that she was seeing a holistic
doctor. She was living in Miami, Florida and she said why don't you contact him and see if there's
anything that you can do you know for treatment if he has any ideas. So I contacted him and he said
he doesn't you know specifically treat just cancer and he kind of just is a more holistic
type approach but he said if he were ever to get cancer or anyone in his family were to get cancer
he would absolutely hands down go see Dr. Kevin Connors and he said he's out in Minnesota
and he said go online you know he has a book online read his book see if it's something that you
would maybe want to do. So I got onto his website I read his book and it just made so much sense to me
you know treating finding the cause of the cancer instead of just treating the symptoms of the
cancer and you know why did this happen to me. So I ended up going to see Dr. Connors I first did
a phone consultation with him and he explained a lot of things to me. I at this point had already had
a mastectomy I chose to do a mastectomy. So the the tumor was removed it was stage one grade one
was not in the lymph nodes and but I just felt like I needed to do something more because
I chose not to do chemotherapy so I ended up talking with Dr. Connors on the phone and he just made
me feel so at peace and he made me feel comfortable with the decision that I made to not do chemo
because I feel like a lot of the traditional medicine doctors just push you into that direction
and you know he did tell me there's a time in a place for chemo and you know it does target fast
growing tumors however in my case I had already had the tumor removed so I I just felt a connection
with him and I felt really comfortable with you know not doing chemo after I talked with him but he
said there are things you still need to do you know and he explained to me the genetic testing and
the applied kinesiology process and I was curious myself just to know what the cause of my cancer was
also so my I booked a flight and I went out there I'm from Cincinnati and I went out there to see him
in November and I found out the cause of my cancer was the flu vaccine which is amazing to me because
it's pushed so much and I am a physical therapist and I worked in a hospital and they made me get
the flu vaccine every year which I will no longer be doing that but yeah and did the genetic testing
I found out a lot of things I should and should not be eating and I just felt so comfortable
after seeing him and having a decision made in the direction that I was going with my treatment
and I felt very at peace with that because I was lost for so many months trying to figure out
what to do and where to go with the whole treatment so yeah it's been two a little over two years now
and I'm doing well I'm still sticking to my diet plan that he recommended and taking the supplements
and I made a lot of lifestyle changes but yeah I feel like he he was just God sent me to him and
that was the the direction I was supposed to go with my my treatment so obviously the right
machine I use as well so but yeah I feel like he has so much knowledge and so much information and
there's such a different world out there with alternative cancer treatment and he and I talk all
the time about how wonderful it would be to have traditional medicine combined with alternative
treatment how many people would benefit from that so I look at things totally differently now I don't
just do whatever the doctors tell me to do in fact I don't even really see a regular doctor any more
other than just like a yearly physical same thing for my children I've got two boys and I will not
vaccinate them we found out some genetic testing with them as well so yeah it's just open my
eyes completely and I'm so grateful for him and I'm so grateful for the decision that I made
and I think anyone who is looking for just obviously the cause of their cancer or just
different treatment either in combination with traditional medicine or you know separately whatever
I think Dr. Conner's is is incredible and I'm blessed to have him in my life and I thank you guys for
the opportunity for letting me share my story and thank you I'll be in touch soon and I hope you
all have a good rest of your day thank you